i'm excited because hot off the presses
this hits news stands today now it's the
new cover which is actually the
subscription cover
of vice president kamala harris on vogue
and it's a gorgeous color to celebrate
the first woman
of color to be elected vice president of
the united states and
vogue initially actually had a different
cover
but people spoke up and they expressed
themselves and requested this change
and most importantly vogue listened yeah
honored them and
magazines just don't do that especially
an institution like vogue ross thoughts
well thoughts you just take one look
here um it's clear which
one is a little more appealing and i
love that vogue heard people when they
said why you choose this one doesn't
make any sense
and change their mind so thank you and
just when you look at this look how
no matter where you lie politically this
is something else though
the first woman ever to reach this
position ever
first of many and as she said she will
not be the last very
great andrew we have tv news that
everyone is buzzing about you ready for
this
bridgerton is coming back for season two
get your streamers get your streamers
girls
our favorite show tv line reports that
lady whistled down herself made the
announcement
on formal letterhead and the cast starts
shooting this spring and the new season
follows the second book in the series so
it's all about the brother anthony
bridgeton and what he's up to
and if you think we're overreacting with
streamers honey we are not because let's
do the bridgeton
numbers for a second it's going bonkers
on netflix it's number one
63 million households watched it in the
first month so we're not alone drew
and it's in the top five most watched
shows ever
in the history of netflix and it just
shows that prayer works honey because it
is coming back
yeah i i love i'm just i'm so relieved i
can't come quick enough all right well
we're keeping the good news rolling with
some delicious
deep discounts in today's food news
people magazine reports that mcdonald's
is celebrating throwback thursdays with
some retro prices so
every thursday from now until february
18th
one item is going on sale each thursday
for a retro price
this thursday a small shake is just a
quarter
ross i know that's five cents more than
the shake was in 1955
fun fact they called them malts back
then
and uh i got a hot date with a large fry
on february 11th
that's right it's gonna be super hot
[Music]
you